it is time to talk pet of the week
animal foundation is here CJ you have
this adorable pup who is this this is
pita chip oh my goodness look at these
ears she's so sweet she is she is one of
the most laid-back cuddly dogs we have
she just wants to be in your lap all the
time she is nice and lightweight too you
said about 30 pounds yeah she's about 30
pounds so that perfect medium size
medium yeah and so friendly
um how old is she she's approximately
two years old
and she loves belly rubs there we go
good girl she'll tell you what she wants
what kind of family are you looking for
is she good with dogs cats people she's
great with dogs she goes to our play
group every week so she's definitely had
her fun every time she gets the Zoomies
as soon as she gets out of her kennel up
but then she really gets laid back so
she's she's great with either a
laid-back family or an active family
she'll modify herself to fit in your
family and do you think she probably
won't get much bigger no no she is full
grown and she's already vaccinated
spayed so she's ready to go she's ready
to go so peta's animal ID is a one two
six seven five one three if you're
looking for her specifically but we have
so many that really need homes not just
homes but Fosters even just some time to
get out of the shelter or for those
really young kittens that we need Foster
families for to get them big and strong
so then they can find their forever
homes so so many opportunities to really
help all the animals in the community
Give a Little Love okay well CJ thank
you so much Pita tip you are a sweet
love bug Folks at home go get her go get
yourself a forever home there Peter says
oh it's just the cutest thing in
the world if you want to adopt pita chip
or any other of the animals that they
have and we know they are just so
crowded right now go to the website call
that number on your screen and CJ also
just wanted to remind everybody you know
it's not just cats and dogs they have
fish Turtles rabbits and other animals
as well